well the press known of course
especially the national press
particularly CNN for its scrupulous
political neutrality so it goes without
saying that the hiring of a single
middle-of-the-road former republican
staffers people hysterical about bias
former DOJ spokeswoman Sarah is gore
Flores were just hired by CNN as deputy
political editor according to that
creepy kid who covers media for CNN the
staff over there were furious one
unnamed reporter called it a quote
disaster and said there were ethical
implications to working for someone who
publicly supported Trump of course there
are quite a few former Obama staffers on
the CNN payroll no problem here to tell
us more about all of this is Weiner
reporter Joe Concha who covers the press
for the hill good to see you Joe so I
just recognize Erica's rezaï I know well
and I I think a lot of her but I my
impression is never that she was some
floored right winger I mean I don't know
but I certainly don't have that
impression of her is she and why the
hysteria over this well she's worked for
some pretty moderate Republicans whether
you're talking about Mitt Romney or
Carly Fiorina obviously she was Jeff
Sessions spokesperson and you're right
the headlines are incredible here CNN
hires GOP operative but no journalism
experience to coordinate his 20/20
coverage that was Vox Esquire CNN just
set the new standard for corporate
media's chicken stuff catering to
Republicans again CNN brie catering to
Republicans every analysis study I've
seen has been overwhelmingly negative
towards the president any administration
but but let's put it this way let's say
CNN hired Valerie Jarrod's daughter okay
and she was assigned to cover the Trump
DOJ despite having no journalism
experience whatsoever do you think that
Esquire box and all these other
publications would be going nuts right
now over a hiring like that of somebody
who has no journalism experience but
obviously has a bias and the answer is
we already know the answer because that
actually happened in 2017 and you could
go down the list I mean really good
George Stephanopoulos Wow yeah yeah well
of course you didn't it was barely
reported I mean I wrote about it I think
a lot two years ago but it there wasn't
a lot of coverage on that and again we
see what happened with Hugh Hewitt
at MSNBC everybody was in an uproar
because Andy lack was trying to bring
MSNBC to
right by giving Hugh Hewitt an 8 a.m.
Saturday morning show for a half hour he
didn't get the full hour I was actually
on the show it was quite fun and it was
like what are you doing your attorney in
the Fox News so that's what happens you
hire anybody from the right in
left-leaning news organizations and they
go nuts because it's not conforming to
and the way things have always gone like
what George Stephanopoulos or like what
David Shipley who worked for the Clinton
administration went on to be a New York
Times op-ed editor and the list goes on
Tucker I'm starting to think they're not
really in favor of diversity well
depends on what kind of diversity we're
talking about right I'm talking about
ideological diversity where people are
different yeah they're not into it and
and look it was overblown they're trying
to say that that Sarah Flores is going
to oversee all of the 20/20 coverage no
she reports up the people there are
several people that have the same title
that she does so it's just one person to
try to balance things out a little bit I
mean give CNN a little bit credit in
that regard but then again I would say
that I agree with the left's orly left
leading publications when they say you
could have hired a hundred other
political editors here that can't be
kind of compromised in any way because
we saw what happened at CNN obviously
with Donna Brazile when she got her
hands not once but twice on townhall to
debate questions and pass them on to the
Clinton campaign and said that was my
priority over my priority with CNN
unbelievable Oh joke on show great to
see you thank you good to see you